I have to get we could be at 43 million
if I want 45 and I'm just deserving of
that and that is that the rate you're
gonna give me 45 million really takes
some time and really look at who you're
surrounding yourself with need
motivation watch a top ten of belief
nation what's up at seven my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have an amazing gift inside you that
I want to see explode out onto the world
so let's get your motivation to attend
and get you believing in you grab a
snack and chew in today's lessons from a
man who went from having his father shot
and killed when he was only 2 years old
and being nicknamed puffs because he
would huff and puff when he got angry to
becoming a three-time Grammy Award
winning artist and with a net worth of
over 800 million dollars being the
richest hip-hop artist in America he's
Sean Combs and here's my take on his top
ten rules a success volume to enjoy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one have a champions mindset for
like the weekend at 14 when the
soundtrack comes out if so bump somebody
I think I love you yes what's next
what's next I got a kid I'm not gonna
stay down I'm not gonna stay flying down
I'm not I can't do it man I can't do
that
what's next give me something else what
can't you do I could do it I could do
anything
rule number two be competitive I speak
to my kids like you really go and do
that is that great is that gonna make a
difference are you sure that's what you
want to spend your time doing so that
competitive thing just opened up a big
door because that's one of the things I
will I want to instill in you guys I'm
looking at and and and and I shaped my
career sometimes I use it I used the
muse of LeBron James LeBron and he
motivates me every day I see him he's
he's up at 6:00 in the morning he's
playing his music he's loving what he's
doing he's conscious he's he's working
out at 6:00 in the morning you don't
have to really work out at 6:00 in the
morning he's working out at 6:00 in the
morning harder than everybody else
that's one of the keys that's why you'll
say I'm number one a lot this is a fact
I wanted more than enough almost
everybody in here I wanna I wanted more
than almost everybody in here
that's what I'm talking about you gotta
stand up for yourself and be able to
compete that's right and you got to put
the work that it's gonna take to do it I
don't know if you're gonna do the same
work as I'm gonna do I'm gonna read up
on it I'm gonna say they're gonna be
like yo let's go to Lipton I'll be like
I'm not gonna live tonight I gots to get
to the back hey you let's go let's let's
smoke some I can't now I'm not smoking
they're rich all right now I gotta get
to the bag there's a time and a place
for everything there's a time and a
place for everything but you have to be
ready we got the same 24 hours you gotta
use your time wisely and you have to be
ready to really really do the things
other people aren't trying to do rule
number three know your self-worth within
business I mean especially being black
can be you know a barrier to entry or
you know barrier to moving forward and
you said I wasn't allowing them to treat
me like a black man and how do you do
that you have to be able to walk away
you know it's a lot of cats out here to
get a taste of the money and when it
comes time to doing that deal and really
being in that ruthless negotiation they
really can't stomach walking away I'm
really really crazy I will walk away
we could be at 43 million if I want 45
and I'm just deserving of that and that
is that the rate you're gonna give me 45
million if we could hear the voice
inside you is the voice yelling at you
like you know like like you can do it
and positive or sit like you ain't you
ain't done enough and push you to go
further higher like what it what is the
voice saying to you you too bad as my
daddy ever built you a King King put it
on a king get a pop get him come on yeah
yeah when putting people it's funny
kids let's do it black excellence let's
go
ruling reform is do what you love now
people might not know this but the love
of your life is performing isn't it yeah
that that right there is just as a
ringmaster as a showman you know I
always have kind of kind of like built
my persona using the muse of PT Barnum
mhm and PT Barnum you know he wasn't
like the most talented person that was
out there but he was presenting the
lions and tigers and bears all the
midgets and the cars and you know the
the lady with the sword and the trapeze
and that was his forte and that's my
forte is is a platform as a collaborator
there's a producer curator and so that
performing in that aspect of being like
the like the conductor the conductor The
Wizard of Oz for all this talent that
I've nurtured to come out and to
entertain you it's something that I love
I love seeing people entertained rule
number five be serious about your dreams
so I would say the mind the mindset that
you have to have you definitely have to
be a little crazy you know your your
faith in your belief has to be crazy you
have to you have to see what's not there
and manifested to be in there but the
mindset is that I was a dreamer I was a
dreamer I started this whole thing as a
dream and then the day that I turned
into the combination of a dreamer and a
realist that's when I started to really
go you know and that's that's saying
like don't be afraid to close your eyes
and dream but then open your eyes and
see the reality of what it's going to
take for you guys to be successful that
mindset that relentlessness that
craziness
and really facing reality or what its
gonna take to achieve your dream is
something that that I think we all have
to have if we really really really try
to get in not trying to play around rule
number six create with authenticity you
are an incredible marketer what is the
key to getting to when you create a
product be it vodka jeans or an album
whatever what is the key to then making
a lot of people want that thing shout
out to all my entrepreneurs and a house
any entrepreneurs in the house yeah um
when I create when I create that thing
it has to be uncut you know that's
really when I've had I've had my best
marketing wins is when it had a story
behind it when it has some heart behind
it and and it was it was it was
authentic it was really really true it
wasn't anything that was like inspired
by like you know just just a regular
Madison Avenue type of ad agency it's
you know very very very disruptive yeah
has to be matter is it something that
matters to people it has it has to be
something that evokes some emotion you
know it has to be something that people
care about has to be something that they
that they that they want rule number
seven hustle I was from Harlem and I
moved to Mount Vernon when I was like 12
I didn't really know anybody I knew that
I wanted to start thinking about what I
was going to do with my life and 12
years old yeah 12 yeah so you know I
started delivering papers and I had a
paper route and started delivering
multiple papers I wasn't supposed to
have a paper route but I made a deal
with the you know some of the paper boys
in the neighborhood that were going to
college let me deliver your papers and I
seen y'all half the money so they was
with that and that's really how I
started to get my hustle on and just
like I ran to get the tape I would make
sure that I put the paper inside the
door so to all the ladies wouldn't have
to
come out their house in the cold so it
was always about doing like the best and
the greatest job I could do living in my
learning there was just one Kingdom on
run there was one guy that made it out
of my learning and it was it was Heavy D
and so I had all my heroes and stuff
from Harlem when I moved them on Vernon
and then you know I saw my first rap
star and I could you know he lived in
the area you know I was so consumed with
rap and I was just so in love with it
and the Heavy D was just so fly like in
it he was a big guy he was dancing and
he was like he was like almost like the
flies that came out of hip-hop because
he's a big guy flying just straight fly
and I'm saying from his haircuts to the
suits to the Teddy Riley combined it on
being hip hop so he was just like a guy
that I was like I gotta meet this guy
you know what I would wait around the
pizza shop that he would come to I would
just sit outside the pizza shop on one
day he came in the pizza shop and you
know I said to him you know I want to
talk to you about being your manager
like like when I went all the way
without this is like when I was like 17
you know and so I'm like I'm gonna be
your manager you know I'm not really
knowing the game I'm not really can if
you had a manager I'm like you know a
number an opportunity or might as well
go for the gusto and he like kind of
like laughs that means like you crazy
you know I'm saying he bought me a slice
of pizza and I was telling him you know
I really want to be in the music
industry you know and you know I'm
interning now with WBLS that was the
radio station but I really really really
want to get down with you and uptown and
then I said you know you know maybe if
you give me a meeting with Andre Harrell
and he was just like yeah yeah that
sounds good sounds good he's just like
you know you were you a different type
of guy like I like your hustle and where
you're coming at me and he said let me
see what I could do
how many wants to do that it took like
maybe eight months of like persistence I
used to met I remember I went from
stalking him at the piece of shop
to light it was like a fork in the road
to like where like he would have the
variable to the left to go to his house
but then it was I gonna kind of a Main
Street so I used to just walk up and
down that block the hope to see his car
to be like it was like I was on the
block I had no problem with playing
myself you know probably any of that I
just had my I was on the prize and I was
excited to see him I was excited to be
chasing my dream to be walking up and
down the sidewalk
you know just making sure he didn't get
him Barris a little bit in the time it
just perfectly and he drove past me like
three times I never caught him there but
I got I got enough heart one day I said
I'm just gonna walk up to his house like
I need this how bad I need this I'm
gonna walk up to his house and then I
was like now you can't ring the doorbell
and then I was just I just made sure
that I would I would walk by his house
and one day he was outside and I said
you know I really need you to you know
make this call for me and then you know
he you know that he had the cell phone
and I guess you know it was kind of big
and everything and he pulled it out he
made the call and he set up he set up a
man for me to meet with you rule number
eight surround yourself with greatness
the road to the bag is definitely tied
to your team and the company that you
keep if you are surrounding yourself
with different energies that's not on
the same wavelength as you if they not
praying for you inspiring you supporting
you for showing you a better way
hello remove them immediately or you
could take them to church pray for
taking the church but you can't help
them get there oh you got to take care
yourself you know what it's called it's
like we talked about the other day is
like being on the airplane and the thing
come down you got to take care of
yourself first
you know then put the mask on put the
mask on really take some time and really
look at who you're surrounding yourself
with look who's to the left and to the
right of you ain't like minded are they
discipline today pushing
forward it's so simple for us to solve
this a lot of the hardest problems are
so easy to solve we just have to take
those steps which are hard and be
mindful of that because trust me that
energy is gonna affect you if you're
around thousand gangsters you gonna be
in jail if you're around casters
talking- you're gonna be- if you're
around some brush you're gonna be rope
broke freeze puffing around some month
if you're around god and some money you
on your way you're on your way
you're on your way I want to make some
money I can't make I can't really be
successful by myself I need other people
around me so you where you are as great
as your team rule number nine is be
super fearless talk about how to be
super fearless especially you know in a
context where you you're not in physical
danger you're not in economic danger so
what is super fearless mean at your
level
super fearless is really wanting true
change I feel like I feel it's because I
have a fear and and and and that fear is
that things are not going to change and
you know we're gonna continue to go
backwards you know as a black man I
can't get to this point have six kids
and not care about my race my people and
so when I look at you know I was
watching the movie
I'm not your negro anybody here sorta
okay James Baldwin yes yes and nothing
has really changed and nothing has
really changed and you know that's what
I fear so I have to be fearless because
I have to be a part of the change and
what that comes is what that comes with
is is is really being a taking some
responsibility to you know to think not
to think outside of yourself I feel I've
evolved and going from me to we and when
you have that type of responsibility
then then you don't have no time for
fear because you can really make the
change but if you're scared you're not
gonna change nothing and so that's what
my fearlessness comes from and rule
number ten the last one before some
special bonus clips for you is have fun
some of these are socks some of these
are water and you're just gonna
depending on if Mark gets the question
right
he gets it wrong you have to take a shot
all right all right mark on the periodic
- what is I was late on the bus we got
there he came after the buzzards okay I
pick one which one was that aquahydrate
baby the greatest ace of water in the
world Pacific oceans and the Pacific
Oceans are two of the five oceans what
are the other three don't play for him
Lake Tahoe
Lake Winnipesaukee Lake Michigan no he's
off you gotta make a shot and the Panama
Canal that was so close
Arctic Indian Ocean an RKO [ __ ] and
southern ocean get a man get a man gonna
get a get at me
[Applause]
what is it yeah I'll get the girl no no
no you know I have a parrot and what my
parents says me coming to my house what
[Music]
now I've got three very special bonus
clips for you from Sean Combs around
meditating being a role model and a
really inspirational rant that I think
you guys gonna enjoy but before that my
question today is around rule number
eight which was being around greatness I
want to know who the person in your life
is that had the biggest positive impact
on you either somebody that you've met
face-to-face or somebody that you
listened to online or an author who's
had the biggest positive impact in your
life that is part of your greatness team
I would love to hear from you please
leave it down in the comments below
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
and enjoy the bonus clips
what is your strategy for dealing with
distractions that's a great question yes
something that is that you've heard
about you've heard about this but it's
that thing like are you willing to go to
where you need to go and get out your
comfort zone the number one thing that
has been able to help me with
distractions is two things one of them
is prayer just taking two minutes to
quiet everything out and talk to God
then the second thing which I was I
can't do this I get I can't even believe
I said that it's meditation meditation
if if that's one thing y'all take away
with which from today it's just go on
YouTube and say ten minute meditation
smooth music so I'm typing anything ten
minute meditation I gotta go see my girl
she's mad at me you know I'm saying like
whatever it is type it in and and just
just really kind of clear your mind
I'm really trying to inspire you know
I'm trying to be a platform of
inspiration during the time where I feel
inspiration is needed but I started out
you know I just wanted to make some
money you know I woke up one day and
there was like seven roaches on my face
and I was like I gotta do something
about this I don't like this feeling
right here and you know it just started
out as me want to take care of my family
and then you know then I want to make
people dance then I want to show the
world that you know we could be you know
not just rapper's athletes that there's
you know other jobs for us in on
executive side of things and you know as
time has gone on what motivates me now
is to really really inspire people to to
be a part of the change that is coming
and now we're all gonna be a part of
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that we believe that
people need passion and not one drop of
most self-worth depends on your it's
supposed to mean
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or absolutely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten most a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details